A Brighter Future.
Do you think futurists can really predict what's going to happen?
In fact, "futurists" don't predict the future.
Instead, they pay a great deal of attention to trends and issues that will impact our future.
They then ask people to consider the implications of those trends and issues...
...for their business, industry, profession, government, or country, for themselves or for the world.
As your family, group, or organization makes plans for the future,...
...they need to see themselves in context.
They must consider the political, economic, social, technological, environmental,...
...demographic changes, and other forces that are likely to impact them.
Likewise,...
...they try to imagine how things will change because of those different forces working together...
...or against each other.
We might call those who pay attention to trends and issues as being "in touch".
Those who don't are usually called "out of touch".
Rather than flying blind, futurists help us see the airspace in front of us.
They can help us develop scenarios and...
...test our assumptions about the nature of the future.
The World Future Society...
...plays a key role in bringing people "in touch" with the future and together from many disciplines,...
...ranging from education and medicine to technology and security...
...help others see what the future may be like.